in san francisco they are in the midst
of
an uncertain transition
at the quarterback position we don't
know when the transition is actually
going to occur you've got them at number
five despite this question of who the
quarterback's gonna be
if it's jimmy garoppolo and they do
finish among the best teams in the nfl
doesn't that guarantee another year on
the bench for trey lance in 2022
we'll see i mean you never can tell if
jimmy garoppolo
is healthy for the for the second time
and only in four years
maybe so
but
i just think right now the reason i put
them so high is because what has stood
in the way
of the 49ers in the last
in three of the last four years what
stood in the way is that they have not
had an above average quarterback
uh they haven't had a top ten
quarterback playing in three of those
four years
now in in the year
much of the year in 2019 when they
reached the super bowl garoppolo was
playing at a very high level
so now
when you look at the 49ers if garoppolo
gets hurt you've got to figure that trey
lance and maybe trey lance takes the job
you don't know but you've got to figure
that trey lance is going to give them a
lot better play than either beathard or
mullins you know so
i just look at this as a quarterback
depth call and look a lot of people
wrote to the column this week
and i'm going to use one of the letters
on monday and they wrote to the column
and they basically said
the 49ers are the biggest myth in the
world
they have had you know they've won six
six and four games
other than the year they won the super
bowl why do people keep overrating them
and it's a very simple reason
in two of the last three years
they have had to play the majority of
the season
with a a a scrub quarterback
and so at this point
i think the quarterback will make all
the difference it'll help to have nick
bosa obviously uh healthy for the year
but they are going to have the kind of
play and i think
depth on offense as well
that's going to
put them very close and make it a a a
rams 49ers tussle at the top of that
division
they have willingly though thrust
themself into this strange
position of we still have jimmy g and he
took us to a super bowl and he was one
throw away from winning that super bowl
but
because he
wasn't healthy the year before or the
year after we've decided to move on they
made the huge investment and i just i
don't
i don't yeah if they have a plan they're
not sharing it with us if the plan is to
make us all not know what the hell
they're going to do mission accomplished
i still don't know what's going to
happen and how this is going to play out
and i don't know that it's good for trey
lance to sit on the bench all of this
year once you've given up that much to
go get him we'll see how it plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports